Welcome.
We're with the master and the disciple, the elder scholar and his young student, and the first lesson after the covenant.
The architecture of creation laid down with mathematical precision, beginning with what kind of first the maker is.
Seven letters in the command, 12 letters in the three words the cosmos is signed with the signature of its own genesis.
So for you listening, we are stepping into a really remarkable
10th century is mainly compilation today.
Yeah, it's quite the text.
It really is.
Our mission is to explore how the author of this chapter envisions the universe actually being built.
We're looking at an architecture of existence that isn't constructed through the physical cooling of matter, but through mathematical precision.
and articulated speech.
Which is just a striking starting point, honestly, especially when you just pause to picture the narrative moment unfolding here.
The disciple has literally just taken the covenant.
Yeah, his tears have just dried.
Exactly.
He has formally bound himself to the party of the divine, which fundamentally alters his whole life trajectory.
So you might logically expect the scholar to start with immediate practical things.
Rules of conduct, ethical precepts, maybe rituals.
Yeah, the daily stuff he now needs to perform.
But the teacher doesn't start there at all.
He starts with cosmology.
He begins with the sheer, staggering architecture of everything that exists.
And the text is really deliberate about that sequence.
The disciple receives this teaching the way one receives the structure of a building.
It's the foundations of a building received before the frame.
It is architecture, not improvisation.
Because you can't hang the drywall before the concrete is poured.
Precisely.
And for the disciple, understanding the nature of the cosmos is the concrete.
The very bedrock of that foundation consists of three distinct declarations about who the originator is in relation to what he made.
Which sets up this really fascinating philosophical boundary line, doesn't it?
does.
The first declaration is that the maker is the absolute originator of things.
You know, the one who granted existence to everything.
The second is that this creation was initiated without any template.
No blueprint lying around to serve as a model.
None at all.
And the third is that he is the first of every first and the inheritor of all existence.
So to summarize the doctrine laid out here, a law is completely unlike a craftsman copying a pattern.
And that distinction is crucial to grasp.
It is essentially A philosophical offensive.
If we connect this to the broader landscape of ancient thought, these declarations systematically refuse several entrenched ideas.
Like the Greek Demiurge.
Yeah, exactly.
They refuse this picture of a cosmic artisan who improvises a universe out of pre-existing chaotic raw material.
They also refuse the idea that the Maker is simply a being among other beings.
Someone whose firstness merely means arriving chronologically earliest on a timeline.
Yes.
The modern scholar Paul Walker calls this specific theological move the negation of seriality.
Let's unpack that concept for the listener because well, negation of seriality sounds super dense, but the mechanism is incredibly elegant.
It really is.
Instead of viewing the originator as simply the first item in a long sequential chain of events, this argues he stands entirely outside the sequential order that is being brought into being.
Firstness here is categorical, not chronological.
Which completely shifts the paradigm.
It anchors the concept beautifully.
In the chapter on iron, verse 3, the originator names himself the first and the last, the ascendant and the intimate.
The scholar's concept of being the first of every first is a doctrinal expansion of that specific verse.
Categorical supremacy.
Exactly.
He is first because the category of existence itself relies entirely upon him.
There's a highly specific philosophical grammar from the thinkers of the time that captures this origination out of nothing, totally devoid of material and a model.
Yes, a prominent Fatimid philosopher named Asi Gistani reconstructed this precise understanding of the creative act.
And he used the technical term ebda to capture this
specific act.
Origination out of nothing.
It's a huge distinction.
He insisted that true origination leaves absolutely no room for raw materials or borrowed designs.
But you know, that raises a profound mechanical problem.
Because of the specific kind of material, first the maker is.
The act of making cannot be physical shaping.
If you aren't a craftsman molding clay, because clay implies pre-existing material,
How does a universe actually get made?
The mechanism has to be something infinitely more subtle.
Exactly.
The scholar explains that the initiation of creation began with a primordial light.
And from that light, 3 distinct words branched out.
And it is really important to emphasize for anyone listening that this is completely pre-physical.
We are so accustomed to thinking of light in terms of physics, you know, like photons, waves, radiation from a star.
But the scholar insists on a strict distinction here.
Yeah, this is a subtle foundation existing prior to the
conditions under which physical light can even be measured or defined.
And in the technical vocabulary of the tradition, this subtle foundation is known as nir.
So from this spiritual luminescence, 3 words branch out.
And they don't appear simultaneously.
They follow a highly specific descent.
A sequence.
Yes.
The first of these three branches is pure intention, the boundless desire to originate.
Which the tradition recognizes conceptually as errata.
Then, deriving directly from that intention comes the directed command.
And finally from the command comes the saying, the beginning of all creation is by a will, executing a command through speech.
The revelation itself frames this exact mechanism in the chapter Yesen, verse 82.
It states that the command, when a thing is intended, is only to say to it, be, and it is.
If you read that verse against the scholar's 3 words, the alignment is flawless.
When he intends represents the will.
His command is the second step.
And to say to it represents the speech.
The scholar isn't inventing a new framework.
He's methodically unfolding the mechanics of the verse.
Henry Corbin, analyzing this exact architecture, observes that the triad is read by the tradition as a graduated procession.
Oh, I see.
Each station gives birth to the next.
Yeah, drawing its reality from the step above it.
Yet none of these stations are a part of the originator himself.
They are the initial acts.
Following that profession, the pure intention solidifies into a directed order, which possesses direction and an addressee.
The text designates this specific stage of the descent as Amester.
Which leads to a vital, practical point raised by Khalil and Donnie.
Oh, about the perpetual nature of it.
Yeah, exactly.
It is easy to hear this and imagine a punctual, one-time event trapped in the ancient past.
a moment billions of years ago.
But this creative act is perpetual.
It's happening right now in every standing thing.
The sheer existence and law-like behavior of the natural world, the gravity holding you in your chair right now as you listen, is the perpetual manifestation of this action happening in real time.
Finally, this directed order becomes audible and effective in the realm of made things.
The term for that final dense articulation of the sequence is qual.
And the precise phonetic sequence of this saying is kun faya kun.
It's not a lengthy command.
It's an instant realization.
Exactly.
The English translation be and it was really captures that immediacy.
The scholar pauses heavily on this sequence because the order is the doctrine.
What we are witnessing is subtlety densifying into articulation.
It is intention becoming directed command, becoming audible speech.
And that represents A profound paradigm shift for most of us because when we think of density today, we usually think of a big bang cosmology.
We think of something hot and rarefied, cooling down over eons and condensing into heavy matter.
Density, for the modern mind, is a thermodynamic cooling phenomenon.
Yeah, but the text is asking you to completely flip your mental model.
Density here is not cooling.
Density is articulation.
Think about when you have a brilliant, complex idea in your head that has pure intention.
It is fluid, boundless, highly subtle.
But the second you try to explain that idea to me, you have to force it into language.
It becomes denser.
Yes, it loses its infinite nature because it's now trapped in words with specific boundaries
and a specific address.
Speech is denser than intention because it has shape.
And the visible heavens and earths are denser still because they are shaped speech embodied.
The further from the source, the more articulated the act becomes.
Which means the contemplative path for the disciple is just this diagram read in reverse.
The spiritual exercise is to ascend from articulated density back upstream, moving past the spoken boundaries toward the subtle pure intention.
And as the master is explaining this, let's notice a structural seed he is quietly planting in the disciple's mind.
The numbers.
Yes, we have 3 words.
One is singular, the will.
The other two form a pair, command and speech.
One alone, then a pair.
The alphabet of creation is being laid down.
The commander of the faithful, peace be upon him, sketches this exact same descent in his opening sermon.
He does.
In the book, widely recognizes peak of eloquence.
The text describes creation as an act without a model preceding it.
From will into directed command into articulated form is captured perfectly in the sermon collection.
But here's where we hit the barrier between the spiritual and the material.
How do these three primordial invisible words actually become the physical cosmos we can touch?
The transition point.
The scholar teaches that from the luminescence, air was created.
Air is the first of the seven physical principles.
And air is completely singular.
It mixes with everything, encompasses everything, but it was unpaired.
Every other entity in this world has a pair.
Hot and cold, soul and body, wet and dry.
But air alone is unpaired, pointing symbolically to the one who has no like.
I mean, that sounds like wordplay.
How is naming air unpaired different from picking the symbol you wanted in advance?
It feels like the scholar is just looking around his environment, noticing that air is everywhere, and retroactively assigning it a convenient theological meaning to make his system work.
That is exactly how a modern mind would approach it.
But the scholar is not looking at nature and making up a poem.
He's operating within a strict, pre-existing textual framework.
The pairing principle found in the Quran.
Precisely.
Specifically, in the chapter on the winnowing winds, verse 49, it declares that of all things, 2 mates were created as a sign.
The verse establishes pairing not as an observation, but as a universal cosmic rule instituted by the maker.
So if everything must be paired by divine decree, an unpaired element is an anomaly.
Exactly.
Therefore, any deliberate exception to a universal commanded rule is mathematically and theologically significant.
Air is the deliberate exception that proves the cosmic rule.
Its unpaired nature points directly back to the unpaired originator.
It isn't an arbitrary choice.
It's A structural necessity demanded.
I see.
The logic holds together from within its own foundational premises.
It does.
Next, from the three primordial words come three more principles.
Water, darkness, and physical light.
These 3 derive from the preceding reality, and then they produce their own denser pairs.
The densification again.
Yes.
Water pairs with smoke.
Darkness pairs with the thickness of mud.
Physical light pairs with fire.
You now have air, which is the unpaired king, governing 3 pairs.
Seven principles in total.
Wait, I want to make sure the listener understands the logic of those pairs.
bearings.
Why does water pair with smoke or darkness with mud?
It can't just be a random list.
It is entirely based on the mechanism of densification we talked about earlier.
Think about the behavior of the elements.
Water, when heated or dispersed, loses its liquid boundary and becomes a dense enveloping smoke or mist.
Oh, and darkness, which is the heavy absence of light, settles and solidifies into thick, inert mud.
And physical light, which is active and luminous, combusts and densifies into burning
fire.
The subtle element generates A denser mate.
And from these seven principles, the visible universe is finally built.
The outward cosmos comes from the denser members of those pairs.
From smoke, the outward forms of the seven heavens are shaped.
From the thickness of mud, the seven earths are formed.
This is grounded deeply in the chapter on detailed explanation verse 11, which speaks of the heavens while they were smoke.
So the scholar reads that verse with absolute cosmological seriousness.
The smoke is not a metaphor.
It is a necessary stage of densification in the architecture of reality.
Let me trace this back to ensure we have the whole picture.
We have an intricate ladder.
A pre-physical luminescence branches into intention, command, and speech.
Those produce air alongside 3 pairs of subtle and dense elements, water and smoke, darkness and mud, light and fire.
The densest elements of those pairs become the physical universe itself.
And here is where the architecture becomes breathtakingly precise.
The scholar returns to the three primordial words and simply counts the letters.
The phrase that names will, command, and speech comprises exactly 12 letters in the original language.
And the command itself comprises exactly 7 letters.
The 7 letters of the originating command produced the seven principles we just walked through.
And the 12 letters of the three primordial words produced A 12-fold signature on the cosmos.
Yeah, I don't buy that, yet deriving cosmic patterns from letter counts sounds like numerology dressed up as theology.
It feels incredibly similar to the human brain's natural tendency to find patterns in noise.
We count things up, find a 7 or a 12, and claim the numbers possess some magical property.
I totally understand the skepticism.
We are so heavily conditioned by natural theology.
You know, natural theology works like this.
A person looks at the physical world, observes a pattern, like the spiral of a shell or the orbit of a planet, and then works backward to infer a designer.
But the author of this chapter is doing the exact inverse.
The modern scholar Farhad Daftary explains this is a form of letterist cosmography.
Letterist cosmography, meaning the letters themselves generate the geography of the universe.
Precisely.
The architecture is mathematically prior to the artifact.
It's a signature stamped on its own work, sevens and 12s, as the alphabet of the originating command appearing in heavens, earths, oceans, days, months, and zodiacs.
So the argument is that the structure of the language, the command, physically dictates the structure of the resulting universe.
Reality is literally poured into the math of the spoken word.
Yes, and this mapping is explicitly anchored in the text itself.
Consider the chapter on repentance, verse 36, which states that the number of months is 12 in the divine register from the very day the heavens and the earth were created.
I see.
The scholar looks at that verse and says,
The text roots the number 12, not in human lunar observation, not in ancient farmers tracking the moon, but in the originating mathematical register.
The architecture comes first.
The language was 12 letters long.
The physical world merely displays the mold it was poured into.
That is a profound inversion of how we normally perceive reality.
If the command literally has 7 letters, and the universe is the dense, articulated speech of that command, then the physical world must naturally, unavoidably fold into sevens.
It has no other shape to take.
I can see the elegance of that architecture.
It isn't numerology.
It is physics derived from divine linguistics.
Seven letters in the command, 12 letters in the three words that cosmos assigned to the signature of its own genesis.
The disciple has been given the foundations of the building.
Because everything later in the master's book will require the young student to read the visible world as a symbol of these invisible mathematical structures.
Exactly.
It changes how you view your physical surroundings entirely.
You are no longer just walking through dirt and looking up at gas.
You're moving through articulated speech.
You are living inside a spoken word.
And I want to bring this fast cosmic architecture directly into your daily reality as you listen to this.
When you next look at a calendar hanging on your wall, what changes?
The seven days of the week, the 12 months of the year, they are no longer just units of time measurement born of ancient convenience.
They are outward, visible, countable signs.
Seven letters in the command, 12 letters in the three words, the cosmos is signed with the signature of its own genesis.
Which countable pattern in your own week?
The 7 of the days, the 12 of the months, the pair beside every single thing has been passing unread.
What would it cost this week to pause just once and recognize it as a signature rather than a mere coincidence?